well my disappointment with podcaster
joe rogan continues to grow the latest
is that rogan called donald trump's
press secretary kaylee mcinanni
the michael jordan of press secretaries
the truth of course could not be more
different kaylee mcinanni one of the
most dishonest press secretaries that i
have ever covered and this dates back to
the george w bush administration quite
frankly um hard to find a more dishonest
press secretary now unfortunately i
think what rogan is falling prey to is
sometimes people sound really confident
but the things they say are absurd this
is sometimes called ben shapiro syndrome
where people will very confidently say
things that are wrong
dishonest absurd pathetic not based in
fact and kaylee mcinanni did that she
sounded very confident but she didn't
really answer questions and she lied
absolutely all the time so this is part
of the continued disappointment with
what has been going on with rogan and
again speculation is he moved to texas
reports are he sometimes hangs around
with extremists like uh republican
governor greg abbott and others and
there may be some sort of i don't know
about audience capture but maybe like um
uh social circle capture of sorts here's
rogan talking about kaylee mcinanny she
was a propagandist i mean when she's
working for the white house she's this
person that
you know answers questions and most of
it the the hard questions are all by
peter ducey on fox so by the way the
here he's criticizing jenn saki who is
biden's former press secretary
who i i have to tell you by and large
was a more honest press secretary of
course of course they all spin but in
terms of out and out lies
saki was dramatically more honest than
any of trump's press secretaries news he
was like the only guy that was like like
pushing back against her and she just
flat out lied on not just one occasion
multiple occasions i mean maybe they had
a narrative that they told her maybe
these are talking parts maybe that's her
job but it's a weird job in the
beginning right
to begin with because it's a job where
you're not even asking the president
you're asking this white house press
secretary yeah so there's a person
you know the only one that was good at
that girl um
mckennany what's her name kaylee
mckinnony the one who worked for trump
that lady was a [ __ ] assassin that lady
had like binders with like footnotes and
they would say some shield that's
interesting because actually cnn said
this and right those were all
distortions and this is the problem with
optics and it's really sad you you
wouldn't necessarily think and in in
rogan's defense not that i need to
defend him maybe he didn't really watch
an entire press briefing to understand
that the binders and the the confident
responses it was built on nothing it was
just smoke and mirrors and she would
like quote it back to them and stuff it
in their face that lady's the best ever
at that job she's the michael jordan of
white house press secretaries she's yeah
i mean obviously that it's really
disappointing to hear that because
a critical thinker
would say let's separate
uh let's separate
substance
from uh tone and delivery let's separate
the facts or lack thereof
from the optics
and i mean listen
kaylee mcinanni promulgated the big lie
it is there a bigger lie
than trump actually won the 2020
election and she lied endlessly beyond
that and defended the indefensible
everything that trump was doing
everything trump did she defended from
the you know covet laced
joyride with secret service around the
hospital like
i couldn't i could spend an hour giving
you the list
there was nothing she would not defend
so when we say she was great at her job
she sounded confident which is something
unfortunately lots of right wingers do
when they say things that are completely
untrue and bogus and of course you can
just go back and find all of the
different things that
she lied about mcinanni made
weeks of press press statements about
trump never downplayed coronavirus trump
literally said we have 15 cases which
will soon be zero there is no bigger
downplaying than when you end up with
100 million cases there's no bigger
downplaying than that and she did that
for weeks and weeks and weeks
she
made the same false claims about the
mueller report that trump would make it
exonerated him it literally did not
exonerate him it said we cannot clear
him of obstruction
the 2020 election lies um
constantly exaggerating number i i'm not
going to bore you with it but the point
is hard to find a more dishonest press
secretary and sadly rogan seems to have
fallen for it
one of our longtime sponsors is monk
pack the keto friendly granola bars and
nut and seed bars i keep these stocked
in my pantry all the time the texture is
great the sweet gooey goodness is
fantastic but each bar has only one gram
of sugar or less just two to three net
carbs and under 150 calories my favorite
lately has been sea salt dark chocolate
people know about my love affair with
dark chocolate but you can also get
other flavors like caramel sea salt
peanut butter dark chocolate and others
then you've got the monk pack granola
bars in flavors like coconut cocoa chip
blueberry almond and honey nut i don't
do keto myself but they are a great
on-the-go snack if you love something
sweet and delicious but without the
sugar which is what i'm going for they
just hit the spot and if you don't love
monk pack as much as i do they'll refund
all of your money just email them my
audience gets 20 off your first purchase
at monkpack.com
when you use the coupon code pacman at
checkout the link is down below